[Music]  this is as close  as families can get to a precious moment  [Music]  well done when i check your watches  because it's certainly active  it's a moment when people across the uk  come together to show their appreciation  [Music]  we're going to do 30 minutes of exercise  have a little bit of fun  have a little stretch at the end leave  my eyes when i saw you walking  fast people need some light-heartedness  fire service has become a key delivery  [Music]  service  [Music]  do remember that things will get better  the sun will shine  never walk alone and believe that to be  true  but things will get better  you're ready to live a bit longer i'm  ready to live a bit longer